Hey youtubers it’s charlie and this week
on arrow what happens in russia stays in russia.
Amanda Waller debuted and Deadshot returned
giving us a teaser of secret six things to
come.
We also learned HIVE is going to be a big
bad this season.
So let’s talk about our favorite moments
and the big DC Universe references and then
I’ll do my review.
So first, Amanda Waller is part of the show
now.
On the show she leads ARGUS, which is like
the DC Universes version of SHIELD.
Instead of helping the avengers they help
the Justice League.
Amanda Waller has always been a frenemy to
superheroes in past incarnations like on smallville
and in the comics.
So I think if she ends up helping Team Arrow
this season it will only be in the most dire
of circumstances.
We will see the suicide squad though, which
is where deadshot comes in.
Diggle was forced to rescue him during his
mission, and now he’s free.
Amanda Waller will probably end up arresting
him in a future episode and forcing him to
work with Bronze Tiger and the other members
of the squad.
Covering the rest of the Russian bases.
Oliver and Isobel totally hook up.
They’re on good terms when the episode ends,
so they might continue to hook up a little
this season, but they’re not going to be
a couple.
Much to the chagrin of Felicity.
I seriously felt bad for her.
You could just see her burning a hole through
oliver’s skull with superman heat vision
eyes.
I liked her line that oliver deserved to be
with someone he cared about.
Meaning her basically.
At comic con, Emily Bett Rickards and Stephen
Amell basically said that Felicity and Oliver
wouldn’t be a couple this season and wouldn’t
really hook up, but that they would become
so close they’d feel like a married couple.
So does oliver hooking up with all these other
women mean he’s cheating on her.
You can write yes or no in the comments.
The other main story was Doctor Ivo back on
the boat.
They’re basically trying to find world war
II japanese super soldiers to try and replicate
some of their serum.
And kill slade.
You see him with this epic burn on half his
face explains how he gets to the one eyed
deathstroke.
But here’s where the DC Universe references
get really cool, so HIVE was mentioned.
In the comics it stands for Holistic Integration
For Viral Equality.
They’re basically like the opposite of ARGUS
and they fight against superheroes.
So they will probably be our big bad and end
up having something to do with the Brother
Blood storyline.
The DC references go even deeper with the
characters on Arrow though.
So HIVE was started by Slade Wilson’s ex-wife,
slade that had half his face burned on the
island and became deathstroke.
Talia Al Ghul is also a member of HIVE.
And remember my Summer Glau Talia Al Ghul
theory.
I so got a Dark Knight rises vibe from her
and oliver’s hookup.
Well what if Isabel Rochev or Talia Al Ghul
or whoever she really is is connected to HIVE.
And HIVE was trying to gain control of Queen
Consolidated to help them takeover Starling
City.
Now that we’re several episodes in we have
enough dots to start connect as the larger
plot of season 2 unfolds.
There’s still a lot we don’t know about
HIVE, Brother Blood and Summer Glau yet.
But I bet they’re all connected.
Let me know what your theory is in the comments
below.
Next week Count Vertigo returns to the show.
Be sure to subscribe to get my video.
But what did I think of the episode.
This was one of the best episode this season.
I give it a B plus.
The Russian field trip was a nice change of
pace visually and it gave us some good character
development for Summer glau’s character
and added some complexity to Oliver’s relationship
with felicity.
We also learned what the secret of those misshapen
skeletons were on the island.
Super soldiers from world war 2.
Like the japanese versions of Captain America.
The deadshot plot was great and gave his character
a place to go, now he’s more than just a
freak of the week.
Kind of teasing us with the amanda waller
suicide squad story that will come later this
season.
One of the reasons I love arrow so much is
that it isn’t afraid to use characters and
events from the DC Universe en masse.
Agents of SHIELD on the other hand has been
kind of stingy with it’s integration with
the Marvel Universe.
But let me know what your favorite moments/favorite
hookups were.
What happens on emergency awesome stays on
emergency awesome.
So I’m posting my weekly video schedule
in the comments below, tomorrow morning I’ll
post american horror story coven and then
in the afternoon I’ll post my next Doctor
Who 50th Anniversary video.
Right now click here to learn more about what’s
going on on arrow this season and click here
to learn what’s happening on agents of shield
this season.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!